Okay, it's now 2:30. We will start the session.
So good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to this mini symposium on
targeting protein degradation and non-canonical
oncogenic signaling.
My name is Anita Belay. I am an assistant professor at Indiana
University, and I am co-chairing this session
today with Dr. Andriy Monastyrskyy from the
Moffitt Cancer Center. It's a true pleasure to be here.
We have an excellent lineup of speaker
today. And just a quick note, we do
not have much time for question after each talk, so talk
15 minutes. So if it finish early, we
will allow one or two question. Otherwise, please, if you have questions, stay
after the end of this session. The speaker will come
to the front and we will allow at least 15 minutes for questions.
So now let me start. I will do a quick
introduction
on the two area that we will cover into this session.
But first, yeah, our disclosure.
So I think we can all agree that cancer signaling
extend now beyond canonical pathway.
Many tumor rely on this non-canonical signaling network,
which are usually highly dynamic and context dependent.
This network can rewire in response to treatment, driving
resistance and tumor adaptation.
Importantly, and one reason we are here today is that
many of these driver remain difficult
to target with current therapy. In this session,
we will hear how this pathway are being targeted through the
development of this new inhibitor.
One of the key challenge in targeting this pathway, but also some
canonical pathway, that many of the underlying drivers
are not easily druggable using traditional approach.
Many of these protein are non-enzymatic or very
simply lack a clear druggable pockets, which
limits the effectiveness of conventional strategy
based on enzymatic inhibition.
One emerging strategy to address this has been the targeting
protein degradation. And I think by now you probably heard
a lot about it, but this approach is driven by molecule
or degrader
that binds both the target but also an E3 ligase,
bringing together this protein into proximity and triggering
degradation, often through the ubiquitination of the target.
And this approach has allowed the expansion of a range of
protein that can now be targeted, protein that
were previously considered undruggable.
So today, this session really reflects this
intersection between new biology and new therapeutic treatment.
I'm not reading all the title, but basically we will
hear about the development of molecular glue degrader, targeting a range
of oncogenic protein, including the ARNT in the
HIF pathway, the HU
in colorectal, and CCN1
in amplified tumor. We will also hear about
this non-canonical signaling pathway, including the
RAS PI3K and how the role of
non-canonical RAS family member.
In addition, we will also cover emerging approach,
including the non-enzymatic HDAC modulation,
epigenetics targeting, and the catalytic RAS
inhibitor that are designed to overcome the resistance.
So with that, I think we can start, and
please join me to welcome the first speaker, Dr.
Olivia Debnath from the Dana-Farber Institute,
who will
present her data on the non-enzymatic
HDAC-mediated repression reveals the
selective stress adaptive mechanisms for cancer
therapy.
Hello, good afternoon. I'm Olivia.
Thanks a lot for having me here. And today we will talk about
non-enzymatic HDAC inhibitors. And I'm coming from
Dana-Farber at Harvard Medical School, Boston.
And I have nothing to disclose, so let's get started.
So HDAC.
Around 30 years and nearly 1,000 clinical
trials, and what do we have? Only a handful of
approvals, and that too for refractory blood cancers.
And until now, we do not have anything major as first
line of monotherapies for solid or intractable cancer.
But why this? The problem boils down to major
structural liabilities. Number one, so you
have 11 zinc-dependent HDAC paralogs that
practically share the identical active site.
This is because of evolutionary conservation and natural selection.
Importantly, a single HDAC paralog sits in many
distinct complexes, starting from SIN3, REST
corepressor, NURD, or mitotic deacetylase.
So if you hit one enzyme, for example, the HDAC1 or 2,
you're not just perturbing the enzyme, you are hitting and
disrupting all of these complexes.
And as a consequence, thousands of genes are de-repressed
all at once. So this is not a mere side
effect.So you are causing a lot of
cytotoxicity and off-target effect,
because of which we have so less clinical success with the
traditional enzymatic inhibitors.
Now, can we shift the paradigm from enzymatic to non-enzymatic
inhibitors? That is, instead of targeting the whole HDAC1
or 2, we try to target specific protein-protein
interfaces that is bringing the whole complex together.
Now, before we move forward to the experimental design, a few word
on the yeast Rpd3-Sin3 complex, because we started
our drug discovery from the yeast.
So what you see over here, Sin3 is a scaffolding
protein, and this recruits Rpd3, which is the
catalytic deacetylase. And for context, this
Rpd3 is the yeast ortholog of human HDAC1
and 2, which is the main histone
acetylase. It's very well known as HDAC1 and 2.
Then you have Ume6. It's a
sequence-specific transcription factor, and this recruits this
complex. And once this is recruited, so this
represses genes such as URA3, and without
uracil, yeast cannot practically grow.
Now, exploiting this biology, we built this cell-based
reporter assay in yeast. So what happens is that, as I told
you, that this Sin3 Rpd3L complex is recruited
to specific gene promoters where it represses URA3.
But then if you have compounds that disrupts this
repression, then you're de-repressing URA3, and
then
you allow the yeast cells to grow without uracil.
So now we have a beautifully direct in cell functional readout,
and using this approach, we screened 52,000 small molecules
from the Hardwards library. So it includes
natural products, bioactives, FDA-approved
drugs. And then we landed up in five
compounds, which is structurally very different from the canonical
HDAC inhibitors like TSA and trapoxin.
And today my talk will focus on the fifth
compound, E6, and specifically all the data that I
will present to you will be focused on E6R, which is its
racemic
enantiomer.
Now, moving forward. So once we identified these five
compounds, we were naturally curious to know if they act as
enzymatic or non-enzymatic inhibitors.
And to test that, we leveraged a luminescence-based
deacetylase activity assay. So the principle is
simple. So the more HDAC activity you have, the more will be the
deacetylation. And this will be
reflected by higher luminescence.
And then we tested it in three different systems, starting from live
yeast cells, which mimic your in vivo cell.
And then you have cell-free system like the HeLa nuclear extract
and also the purified HDAC protein.
Then what you see for the canonical enzymatic HDAC
inhibitors is that for TSA, TRA, and
vorinostat, which is also popularly known as Sahab
inhibitor, you see an inhibition starting from 80%
to 99%, which is pretty nice. But
then in contrast for E6, it's essentially flat.
It's not an enzymatic inhibitor. Now the key question
is, if this compound is not acting as an
enzymatic inhibitor like TSA or TRA, what is its
mechanism of action? And does it produce a distinct
transcriptomic signature as compared to TSA or TRA?
To answer this, we turn to
transcriptomics or RNA sequencing.
So specifically what we did is we treated yeast cells with this
compound, TSA and E6R, and then we compared its
global transcriptomic profile with the complex knockouts, Rpd3
and Sin3 deletion, and also Ume6 deletion, which is a
specific transcription factor that recruits a complex to gene
promoters. And what you see over here is expected with
TSA, because TSA again is a canonical HDAC inhibitor,
so it shares a substantial fraction of differentially
expressed genes with the complex knockout.
But if you focus on E6R here, it has a
pretty distinct profile because it's not sharing the
signatures
with the complex knockouts or with TSA.
And then, there are computational methods to
systematically investigate this.
So what we see over here is a similarity matrix.
Then we can perform test like hypergeometric or Jaccard's index.
So in this heat map, this diagonal represent the perfect
overlap. So you see strong overlap between Rpd3 and
Sin3, and then TSA, as I said before, shares a
substantial fraction of DEGs with Rpd3
and Sin3. But then if you focus on E6R,
then you see clearly that E6R diverges from the
enzymatic inhibitor TSA and definitely from the gene
knockouts.
Now, to dive deeper into this, we did something
called effect size
analysis. So here, basically you are computing the log2 fold change
of the shared genes between TSA, the enzymatic inhibitor, and
Rpd3 and Sin3. So remember, TSA is our positive control in the
experiment. And what we see is expected.
You see this super high concordance of TSA with
Rpd3 and Sin3, but this is expected because a
canonical HDAC inhibitor will mimic the
complex loss.Then moving forward, you see this sharp
contrast with TSA and E6R shows extremely poor concordance
with Rpd3 and Sin3, which is reflected by the very weak
Pearson correlation values. So E6R, our
compound, does not phenocopy the enzymatic loss of the core
complex and shows a modest correlation with TSA.
Now,
then we are sure that E6R does not look like Rpd3
knockout. It does not look like Sin3 knockout.
Then what does it phenocopy? We know that
HDAC or the Sin3 Rpd3L complex has more
subunits beyond Sin3 and Rpd3, so we were
naturally curious to know if E6R is phenocopying any one
of that or resembles some completely independent gene
deletions outside the core complex.
And for that, we turn to Deletome. So this is a
compendium having transcriptome signatures of around
1,500 gene knockouts, so that's almost 23%
of yeast genome. And importantly, they profiled 11
out of 12 HDAC subunit deletions. And moving
forward, what we see reinforced what we know about TSA.
TSA clearly phenocopies yeast HDAC complex deletions.
And you look into our top two hits, so this is Rpd3 and Sin3
deletions, followed by other core subunit
deletions associated with the HDAC core complex.
And now moving forward, what we see with E6R
shows us that E6R is not a canonical HDACi.
So when we do this overlap analysis with Deletome, you see the top
hits is Sis2 and Cst6, but they are not
the core complex members, or
they don't have anything to do directly with the HDAC complex.
And for context, Sis2 is
essential for coenzyme A biosynthesis, and previously,
several coenzyme A derivatives were shown to allosterically
activate HDAC 1 and 2. And Cst6 is
quite interesting because it shares the conserved bZIP basic
leucine zipper domain found in human ATF3 and
ATF4, and this is quite important for the next part
of our result, and this has implications in stress
and senescence signaling. Now, from yeast,
we saw that
we could validate nicely our positive control TSA, and
E6R does not transcriptomically phenocopy
any core complex loss.
Then we were curious to see how do our results translate to
human cancer cell lines and if the results are therapeutically
meaningful. And to validate and to investigate
our results in human cancer cell line, we chose neuroblastoma,
which is a N-MYC-driven, highly malignant pediatric
tumor. And for context, this is a phenotype which is highly
sensitive to HDACi inhibition.
Now, you see that in the invasion assay, so in Panel
B, that both compounds are significantly reducing neuroblastoma
invasion across the concentration ranges, although
TSA is definitely decent than E6R.
But what is important is if you go to the viability assay.
So you look into the TSA figure that at even small
concentration of one micromolar, TSA is pretty
cytotoxic and significantly reducing cell viability.
In contrast, E6R has a broad
tolerance window, so even at large concentration of 25
micromolar,
E6R does not show any cytotoxicity.
So what we can say from here is both compounds significantly
reduce neuroblastoma invasion, although E6R
achieves this without this additional cytotoxic effect that
limits TSA's clinical or therapeutic utility.
And this is also nicely reflected when we perform the RNA-seq
in the neuroblastoma cell line. So we show TSA,
compare TSA and E6R side by side. Then you see the
number of DEGs affected by TSA is almost 6,000.
And if you look into E6R, it's 410. That 14x
fewer genes than TSA. And for your information, we
tried several statistical cutoff, and we
always see that E6R affects a lot lesser genes
than TSA. And then what is important is if you look into the log2
fold change distribution of the DEGs of TSA, it's
pretty broad and near Gaussian, which aligns with broad epigenetic
rewiring these enzymatic inhibitors are supposed to
show. And in contrast, if you look into the distribution of
E6R, you see a spike around zero.
So it means most of the genes are unaltered, and in case something
is altered, it's altered to a large extent, which is manifested by
super high log2 fold change. And mathematically, we
can measure this using metrics like kurtosis.
So in brief, very high kurtosis is high transcriptional selectivity.
So what it tells us is that E6R is presumably
more selective than enzymatic inhibitors.
Now, what are these 410 DEGs doing in
E6R? So what gene set enrichment analysis tells us
is also interesting. So you see a clear
activation of p53 pathway and a strong repression of the
E2F targets over here. So this is what we think is
happening. So E6R somehow disrupt the Sin3 HDAC
complex. So this leads to p53 stabilization.
This in turn drives your cyclin-dependent kinase or
p21 to go up. This in turn inhibits
CDK2, and Rb gets hypophosphorylated, which in
turn can sequester E2F, and you see this strong repression
of E2F target. So what we see is a nice Rb or
p21-mediated cell cycle arrest. And
importantly, this is similar to what enzymatic inhibitors like
TSA or SHH
are previously shown to do. And
this is nice that E6R is converging on the same therapeutic
output, although through a very different entry point.
And then we also have another set of gene set
enrichment results that is nicely supporting the
phenotype we see. So I want to remind you that
neuroblastoma is addicted to N-MYC, so it needs N-MYC
signaling to show this very high proliferation and cater to its
pro-tumorigenic needs. And then with E6R, what we
accomplish is very strong repression of the MYC programs.
So E6R or this novel compound is essentially stripping
off the neuroblastoma cell of itsof its
engine that drives high proliferation, and this goes hand in hand with
strong repression of G2M checkpoint target genes, and
then also very high apoptosis that we see here.
And for context, E6R also moderately represses the
glycolytic enzymes. For example, you have hexokinase or
phosphofructokinase. So if I have to consolidate all the
results from this GCA and pathways, we can say
that together with this p53 going up and repression of
E2F and G2M, so this is a classic
antiproliferative apoptotic state which is induced by
our inhibitor.
Now, we got curious to know that, okay, what E6R is
doing beyond TSA. So in other words, what are its specific
signatures? For that, we did something similar to what we did in E.
So this is gain and effect size analysis.
You are comparing the log to full change of the shared genes.
So above this diagonal, so you have these green genes,
and these are strongly induced in E6R relative to TSA.
And immediately you notice genes like GDF15 and
DDIT3. And these genes like DDIT3 are pretty
interesting because it's pro-apoptotic, and these are
classic ATF4 targets, and DDIT3 is
well-known to target BCL2 family members and drive
apoptosis. And then immediately we realized
that maybe ATF4 is regulating these genes, and
we wanted to unbiasedly identify the major transcriptional
regulators regulating the E6R targets.
And using computational approaches, we found ATF4
is a master regulator of the E6R enriched targets, and
these are few selected candidates that ATF4 is regulating, which
includes ATF3, DDIT4, as I told you, and
importantly GDF15, which is a well-known SASP,
senescence-associated secretary phenotype.
And we are definitely curious to understand more that
if this ATF4 activity is a direct
outcome of SIN3 regulation or it's more of an indirect
effect, and we are planning experiments.
We are planning to do SIN3 ChIP-seq with and
without E6R and see what happens.
And again, ATF4 is a key component of integrated stress
response, which is activated during cellular stress, such as
nutrient deprivation, hypoxia, and oxidative stress.
And together with p53 and 21, it's driving the senescence
signaling. We also have some work in progress
where we perform single-cell RNA sequencing similar to
bulk RNA sequencing, where we treated neuroblastoma cell lines with
TSA and E6R. So what's interesting is that if you look into
side by side, that E6R is mirroring
DMSO, and the composition is--
okay, sorry, I will wrap it up.
And it's mirroring DMSO, and you don't see major changes
in cell state composition. So I will quickly wrap up.
So what E6R is doing is that through p53 and E2F
signaling, it's mediating cell cycle arrest and Rb-mediated
senescence. Then it specifically shows integrated stress
response and activating most possibly the pro-apoptotic ER
stress branch. And E6R transcriptional response is highly
selective than TSA. And then cell state composition
mirrors DMSO at single-cell resolution.
And here is my executive summary, and I would be happy to take questions
later on. With that, I would love to acknowledge all members of
Mark Feitelson's lab, my PI, Professor David Hill at
Dana-Farber Harvard Medical School, and all the collaborators I
worked with. Thank you.
Thank you.
Thank you, Aaliyah, for this great talk.
I think we don't have much time, so let's move on to the next speaker,
Dr. Jake Fachman from Neomorph, who will present the data
on molecular glue degrader of the INT
protein.
Good afternoon, and thank you to the organizers for the opportunity to present our
work. My name's Jake Fachman. I'm in the pharmacology group at
Neomorph. We're a molecular glue degrader biotech company located here in
San Diego.
Today I'm going to continue on the story that some of you may have heard on Sunday
about NEO811, a molecular glue degrader against
ARNT for the treatment of clear cell renal cell carcinoma or
CRCC.
So ARNT or HIF1 beta is a transcription factor that plays a
major role in
HIF signaling pathway.
Built on foundational research by Bill Kaelin and all, we know
VHL normally targets HIF1 alpha and HIF2 alpha for degradation
in normoxic conditions. However, during hypoxia or in
CRCC, where VHL is inactivated, HIF1
alpha and HIF2 alpha can become stabilized.
Then it allows them to form heterodimers with ARNT.
This then drives translational
regulation of different pathways, such as angiogenesis through VEGF,
proliferation, and metastasis.
Not only is ARNT central to the HIF pathways, but it also combined with AHR
and drive immune suppression. It does this not only tumor intrinsically,
but also through immune cells themselves by inhibiting
pro-inflammatory cytokines like TNF alpha and driving T regulatory cell
differentiation.
Why we're excited about ARNT and targeting it is it's central to
these three major nodes, and actually, the standard of care for
CRCC targets each one of these, such as immune checkpoint
inhibition,
TKIs and VEGF receptor inhibitors, and more proximal HIF2 alpha
inhibitors such as bel sutafen. So the question for us is, if targeting
ARNT, can we more broadly and substantially inhibit these
oncogenic pathways?Prior to
starting a big drug discovery project on this, we wanted to validate some of the
biology in-house on ARNT.
We know, if you work in HIF, that in vitro culture systems are
difficult, and 2D assays often fail to capture
meaningful phenotypes. And so we really went into vivo really quickly.
We generated an inducible shRNA against ARNT in a
CCRCC cell line. We implanted these cells, allowed them to
engraft, and then induced ARNT knockdown with doxycycline.
After several days, we isolated the tumors and looked for ARNT expression, and as
you can see, we see deep downregulation of ARNT.
Importantly, this leads to nice tumor growth regression over on the right side, and
this is in the A498 system. So again, this validated the
biology, but it also showed ARNT is necessary for in vivo tumor growth.
From here, we decided to do a full drug discovery project.
We put ARNT through our proprietary molecular glue
screening platform, and
were able to identify our lead compound, NEO811.
So a little in vitro characterization of NEO811.
In a cellular degradation assay, we showed that it is a very deep ARNT
degrader with low nanomolar activity.
It's cereblon dependent because we did a cereblon knockout in the same cell type.
It has a favorable selectivity profile.
So in the middle, you can see, again, cellular degradation assays looking at known
cereblon NEO substrates such as CK1alpha, GSPT1,
Ikaros, and SALL4. And we see a really nice window of activity between our
ARNT degradation and any off targets.
We also did multiple
whole-cell proteomics profiling to assess the whole proteome, and again,
we have a very favorable selectivity window.
And then we ran a functional assay, so a dose response showing that we can actually
inhibit the HIF-2 alpha pathway with NEO811.
And interestingly here, we do show a little bit better potency than belzutifan, the
HIF-2 alpha inhibitor in this stuff.
From a drug
property standpoint, NEO811 shows good physicochemical
properties. It's orally bioavailable,
which allowed us to progress into in vivo studies.
So we use the 7860 xenograft system.
It's VHL deficient,
and it relies on HIF-2 alpha signaling.
So we implanted these cells, allowed them to engraft to about 200 millimeters
cubed, and then started oral daily dosing of our compound
NEO811. And as you can hopefully see, we see dose-dependent tumor
growth inhibition at both one and three mgs per kg.
Three mgs per kg gave greater than 50% tumor regression as a single
agent. Importantly, this compound was very well tolerated with minimal
body weight loss over the course of the study.
At the end of the study,
we isolated tumors six or 24 hours post last dose,
performed a western, and I hope you can see, we see deep and
sustained ARNT degradation all the way through the 24 hours.
We also looked at HIF-2 alpha genes, so VEGF and NDRG1, and we
also showed modulation of that, and also dose proportional
plasma exposure for PK. So taken together, we've shown
we can target ARNT, degrade it, it's tolerated, and this
degradation of ARNT actually leads to deep efficacy as a single agent.
So even though we are encouraged as the single agent studies, we wanted to then go
in and say, can we do anything with combinations with other standard of cares,
really to hit these pathways a little bit harder?
And so giving the clinical success of HIF-2 alpha inhibitors, especially
belzutifan recently, we wanted to test NEO811 and belzutifan in
combination.
To have a better window to see any synergistic effect, we
chose low doses here and not full efficacious doses.
So we dosed belzutifan at 1.1 mg per kg and NEO811 at 0.3 mgs per
kg. As you can see, both single agents do still show some tumor growth
inhibition. However, significantly, the combination by the end of 22
days of dosing showed significantly more tumor growth regression than any single
agent, which shows that not only adding a HIF-2 alpha
inhibitor with ARNT, so they're targeting the exact same pathway,
is that hopefully in the future, this will open us up to other combinations of
other standards of care. And again, this was well-tolerated.
During preclinical and clinical studies of the HIF-2 alpha inhibitors,
this is from Peloton Labs and Dr. Brigirulis' lab,
they identified a mutation in HIF-2 alpha,
G323E, which made the tumor cells
resistant to belzutifan treatment or HIF-2 alpha inhibitor treatment.
We actually generated this cell line in 7860s where they
harbor this mutation. In vitro, we showed that was inactive to the
HIF-2 alpha inhibitors where it was active to ARNT degraders.
And so then we put this in vivo. Some of these engineered cell lines are difficult
in model development. They grew a little bit slower and had variable take rates.
And so we actually generated fragments from the model development tumors,
fragmented them, sequenced them to make sure they still harbored the mutation, and
then implanted those fragments subcutaneously for future efficacy studies.
So here you can see, after we allowed them to engraft, we treated them with
belzutifan. And as would be obvious,
it showed no effect here, similar to the literature, where NEO811 still
retained full activity. We isolated the tumors, and again,
assessed for HIF-2 alpha
pathway modulation. And again, belzutifan, similar to the lack of
efficacy, showed no inhibition of its pathway, where NEO811
showed robust inhibition of VEGF.
So that was the acquired resistance to HIF signaling.
What about intrinsic resistance?
So this is a paper, again, from the Brigirulis lab, Chen et al., where they
looked at different CRCCC PDXs,
and they tested them with a HIF-2 alpha inhibitor, a precursor to
belzutifan. And they showed some that were sensitive and some that were
resistant.We went back through the data and reanalyzed it, looking
at gene expression of either HIF-2 alpha or HIF-1 alpha.
And you can see that the sensitive lines in blue dots generally express
more HIF-2 alpha and low HIF-1 alpha, where the resistant ones
generally did the converse, where it was low HIF-2 alpha, high HIF-1
alpha.
So our thinking is, since we're a pan-HIF inhibitor, because we not only
can inhibit HIF-2 alpha, but also HIF-1 alpha signaling, is maybe
NEO811 would actually play a role in some of these
intrinsic resistant models to HIF-2 alpha inhibitors.
So looking at the PDX
line XP490, again, this is the same Chen et al.
paper from Reger's lab, looking at a close analog of belzutifan,
XP490 showed
no sensitivity to either this HIF-2 alpha inhibitor or
TKI. Interestingly, they did a western on these tumor at the end, and you can
appreciate XP490 in the red box showed no to low
expression of HIF-2 alpha. So again, it matched that transcript data from before.
We were able to acquire this PDX from the Reger lab from UT
Southwestern. And you actually have to do orthotopic expansion of these.
So you take tumor fragments, make a slit in the mouse kidney,
implant the fragments, allow them to grow anywhere from one to six months.
Once they're big enough, you excise them, fragment them, and then do subcutaneous
implants. And then from there, we went on to do an efficacy study.
Interestingly, belzutifan, actually at six mgs per kg, daily oral dosing, did
show some tumor growth inhibition.
But you can appreciate NEO811 at three mgs per kg showed robust tumor growth
inhibition, and again, a little bit better than just HIF-2 alpha alone.
Again, these PDXs, they're serially transplanted over time.
So we're doing the PD assessment on these, and they may now express a little HIF-2
compared to the publication, because again, belzutifan did show some activity.
But we're very excited because NEO811 not only shows activity in
acquired resistance to HIF-2 alpha inhibitors, but also intrinsic resistance,
showing this pan-HIF activity may really be a driver in the clinic.
Oh, I talk fast.
All right. So in summary, NEO811, hopefully I showed you, is a potent and
selective cerebral molecular GLU to ARNT.
Its oral bioavailability, which led to a really nice
PD and efficacy. It showed combination effect with belzutifan,
and was able to combat both
intrinsic and acquired resistance to HIF-2 alpha inhibitors.
I hope to have showed you that these data provide preclinical evidence and
scientific rationale to further investigate 811 in the clinic.
And I'm very excited to say we actually dosed our first patient in
January, and this is in CCRCC, locally advanced or
metastatic and unresectable.
So I'll finish with that. I want to thank the Neomorph team.
So almost everyone in this picture touched this project in some ways over the last
few years. I'd like to thank our co-founders.
Phil Chamberlin gave a really nice talk on the same subject on Sunday.
And then our investors and collaborators.
And with that, I can take some questions.
Yes, we
have time for one or two questions.
Hi. A few small
questions.
Relative selectivity of NEO811 for ARNT versus
ARNT2. Have you all looked at what the degron might
be and if you'd be hitting both isoforms or just...
We have looked at ARNT, and some of our earlier molecules, I think, had
selectivity issues, but we have nice selectivity to ARNT2.
The degron, we're not talking about that at this meeting, but in the future, we
hope to do... Our molecular science team will present or publish papers on
that.
The second thing is almost all the data that at least you had in your
presentation was A4987, 860 cells, predominantly HIF-2
cell lines.
Have you all tested UMRC-2s or UMRC-6s, any of the HIF-1, HIF-2 cell
line to see? I know the PDXs
have very low levels of HIF-2, but perhaps what happens when both
exist?
Yeah.
Great question.
With NEO811, we've been limited in testing it because, again, we are trying to move
it into the clinic. With some of our earlier tool compounds, yes, we've tested a
whole slew of them. And again, most of the ARNT degraders are active.
Anything that expresses HIF-2 alpha, and then also UMRC-2 is also active as
well.
And bioavailability in the kidney is good?
Yes.
Last question.
Hi. Nice talk.
So I was curious your thoughts on mechanistically if
the HIF programming that you're inhibiting is leading to
toxicity related to things like an EMT-related cell state,
inability to be plastic in that way, or is it more
related to the microenvironment requiring HIF
metabolic programming that is now inhibited and you get metabolic collapse?
Yeah, that's really interesting.
And again, I think there's a poster ongoing right now.
Our biology lead, Scott Lee, has some of that.
But
how we see it, it's more a global shutdown of not only maybe changing the
immune milieu, even though there are only macrophages in this stuff.
But also, we're inhibiting VEGF, which is the main driver of angiogenesis.
So it could just be vascularization as well.
Again, we haven't really delved too deep into that right now, but that's a great
question.
Thanks.
Thank you, Jake. Our next speaker is Dr.
Ralf Tiedje from Monterosa Therapeutics, and he will
present the data on another molecular glue
degrader targeting the CCNE1.
Great. Thank you very much
for the introduction. Also, thanks for the opportunity to speak here on behalf of
Monterosa Therapeutics,
and show you some data on our cyclin E1 molecular glue degrader
program.
So these are my disclosures. No surprises
here.So I'm very happy to see that there's a
lot of interest in targeted protein degradation at this conference.
So I would like to start with a few remarks about MGDs,
molecular glue degraders, and why we are so excited about them.
So MGDs enable us to expand the target
space very significantly and design selective
degraders against targets that were previously thought to be undruggable
or poorly druggable with other modalities that are currently available.
They are clinically validated, and they retain some of the
advantages of low molecular weight drugs, such as oral bioavailability, but
also more conventional scalable manufacturing,
as compared to some other modalities.
So the key reason why molecular glue
degraders enable us to tap into new target space and to
design selective degraders for new previously undruggable
proteins is that they obviate the need for a binding
pocket for a low molecular weight drug-like compound.
But instead, they work via reprogramming the surface of an E3
ligase component. In this case, cereblon, which is by far the best
studied in the field.
So that cereblon plus the glue now
create an affinity for a target protein
that induces a ternary complex that is stable enough to induce
ubiquitination and then degradation.
So this ternary complex formation
is mediated both by interactions with the glue
and interactions between the ligase and the target protein.
So it's an assisted, enhanced PPI, although in none
of the cases we have studied, there's any intrinsic affinity between the
ligase and the target on its own. And so it's really glue-mediated and can
become nanomolar or even picomolar with optimized glues.
At Monte Rosa, we have built a platform that allows us to
rationally discover and also optimize molecular glue degraders
for targets of interest. And one of these targets is cyclin
E1.
Cyclin E1 is a well-validated oncogenic driver.
It becomes an oncogenic driver through genomic amplification of the
cyclin E1 gene in a subset of cancers.
We see these amplified cancers quite frequently in ovarian,
in endometrial cancer, also in gastric, as well as breast cancer.
So altogether, this is a sizable patient population.
And the best-known mechanism, and probably also the most
relevant mechanism by which cyclin E1
mediates cancer growth, and the data will show that
later, is to form an active kinase together with CDK2 that then
phosphorylates Rb, thereby releasing E2F, which
drives cell cycle progression at the G1 to S transition and
enables DNA replication.
There are also other proposed or documented
mechanisms by which cyclin E1 may contribute to
DNA replication more directly, independently of a kinase
activity, such as through interaction with MCM helicase
complex and other mechanisms.
But the main function is really the CDK2-mediated phosphorylation of
Rb, as you will see.
So we set out to discover selective molecular glue degraders for
cyclin E1.
This is our lead candidate that I would like to share with you here,
MRT55811. It's a potent and selective MGD,
as mentioned. So the selectivity is shown here on the left side in a
proteomics experiment. We intentionally chose an amplified cell line,
in which we engineered an Rb knockout in order to avoid any
secondary effects. So it's only purely what the glue directly degrades, what
you see here, and that's only cyclin E1.
So we are very happy to see that. I'll comment on the Rb
knockout a bit more later.
So in the middle panel, you see a degradation with
nanomolar potency, which leads to Rb dephosphorylation as
expected, and then leads to a cell cycle arrest.
On the right side, this is by flow cytometry, where you can see that really S phase
is completely suppressed
at the point where we get to deep degradation of cyclin E1.
We were very happy and intrigued to see that at the same time we also see
co-degradation of CDK2 and phospho-CDK2.
So here you can see that the dose response of cyclin E1 loss is
pretty much in parallel to when CDK2 and
phospho-CDK2, and then also phospho-Rb go away.
So what we think is that in the amplified setting, that CDK2
is for the most part constitutively associated
with cyclin E1 because there's so much of it and it's constantly around and not
cycling as in a normal cell.
And therefore, we get this co-degradation.
We could show this
by looking at the ternary complex, which is actually a quaternary complex.
We have demonstrated this with recombinant proteins, and what we are
seeing is that the degron, meaning the interaction
surface on cyclin E1 that's bound by molecular glue plus cereblon, is
at the opposing surface of the part that binds to
CDK2, so that all four components can come together,
cereblon, glue, cyclin E1, and CDK2.
And this is probably the predominant
species we are targeting in the amplified setting.
And then we are seeing very rapid ubiquitination of multiple
lysines, both on CDK2 and on cyclin E1,
which we measured by proteomics, and that leads then to co-degradation.
So we think this is an advantage because then it would close the door for any
potential escape pathways that are not cyclin E1, but
CDK2-dependent, such as cyclin E2, cyclin A.
Although we have not seen any evidence for that yet.
So then we characterized our compound more broadly in
a panel of cyclin E1 amplified cell
lines.And also non-amplified cell lines.
So we chose cell lines from cancer indications where amplification is frequent.
And in this matrix here, the cell lines, each column
is a cell line. They are rank ordered by copy number.
And as you can see, there is a block of cyclin E1 amplified cells in
gray in the top row, and a block of non-amplified in white.
And what is immediately obvious is that all the activity we see with cyclin E1
degrader is in the amplified box or bucket, and
there's no activity in the non-amplified cell line.
So blue indicates a GI50 mostly in the nanomolar range, and white is no
activity. If we just quickly jump to the lowest row, there's palbociclib as
a representative of a CDK4/6 inhibitor. We see the exact opposite.
So no activity in the cyclin E or an amplified bucket and all the
activity in the
other cell lines. CDK2 inhibitors, interestingly, are a bit different.
So they do show preferential activity for cyclin E1 amplified
cell lines, and that's more obvious in the lower plot
where you can see the GI50s.
But there are significant overlaps, so there's also a lot of activity in
cell lines that are not amplified.
We have seen this with multiple CDK2 inhibitors, not all are
shown here. With a Wee1 inhibitor and
PKMYT1 inhibitor,
we did not see any differential between the two classes of cell lines.
I'm just mentioning this because there's clinical development for
this type of compound with a cyclin E1 biomarker in the
clinic.
So overall, we are very happy with this profile because we really only get
specifically activity in
a cancer-specific alteration-bearing cell.
And we expect that there's no activity in any
normal tissue and that this modality will be extremely well-tolerated.
This is also supported by the mouse knockout of cyclin E1, which pretty
much has no phenotype.
We were a bit curious why there's this difference between CDK2
inhibitors and cyclin E1 degraders and tried to study
this a bit more in detail. So the mechanism by which we
believe, and based on data, our degrader works is,
as mentioned, that it
degrades cyclin E1, thereby preventing CDK2-mediated
phosphorylation of Rb,
which then basically is linking to E2F
and cell cycle progression. So to short-circuit this whole
system, one can just knock out Rb, and that's what we did.
So we generated isogenic cell lines.
One example shown here, and this completely, or almost
completely, prevents the anti-proliferative effect of a cyclin
E1 degrader, as expected, and showing that the
anti-proliferative effect is fully on target.
Whereas there is
shift of the dose response curve for CDK2 inhibitors,
but they are still active to some extent at higher concentrations.
This could have different reasons.
There are some published literature with proposed hypotheses.
And also,
what we did is we profiled a number of those in kinome panels, and we always
see some additional kinases that are inhibited to various extents.
In this case, only other CDKs, in other cases, also other kinases.
So that could be a contributor, but there's also other proposed mechanisms.
In any case, we believe this is probably something that will also happen
in normal tissue, and we are having some emerging evidence
for that.
So then we went in vivo to characterize our compounds in xenograft models
of cyclin E1 amplified cancer cell lines.
Here, the first example, MKN1, a gastric cancer cell line.
At a dose which leads to complete cyclin E1 degradation,
so basically showing us the optimal efficacy we can get, we were very
happy to see some regression after some time, slightly better than
a CDK2 inhibitor, and we also tested multiple
here at their highest published dose.
At the same time, we see very strong suppression of E2F target genes
at an interim time point and endpoint in this study, again, as
expected,
coupled with a very deep suppression of phospho-Rb and of
phospho-CDK2 as well. So all in line with the mechanism we
observed in vitro, and again, reinforcing that this
is all on-target activity. A similar
picture in two other amplified cell lines here from
ovarian and breast cancer, where we see regression or stasis.
Again, a little bit an edge over CDK2 inhibitors
and deeper suppression of phospho-Rb.
It's actually not shown on this slide, but we have the data.
So with this, I would like to summarize and conclude.
So I've shown you our highly selective first-in-class cyclin
E1 MGD,
previously undruggable oncogene, which is exclusively
active in cancers with a genomic alteration, namely
cyclin E1 amplification, which is very strongly correlated with expression of
cyclin E1.
So we are very confident, again, that this will be a very cancer-specific and
very well-tolerated therapeutic modality.
We have seen strong sensitivity in cyclin E1
amplified cell lines in vitro and in vivo,
and all of this is Rb dependent through the expected
mechanism which differentiates it from clinical
stage CDK2 inhibitors.
My last slide. So I would like to
acknowledge the entire Monte Rosa team and thank everybody who
contributed to all this data, both at the Boston and the Basel
side. A fantastic team to work with.
A special shout-out to Nina Ilic Vidlund and Beatrice
Ranieri, who are leading this program at Monte Rosa, and also Bill
Tahany, who generated a lot of data and made many of the beautiful slides
I was able to share with you today. But also thanks to the
entire team, of course.
Happy to take questions.
Thank you, Ralf. We have time for one or two questions.
Hello. Nice talk. So I find that you're showing
the cell panel, and there are some cells which is
CCNE1 amplified, but it's not
respond very well to the compound.
Yeah.
Why do you think there are any biomarkers or any reason for that?
Yes, absolutely. A great question. And I didn't go in detail. Yes.
So one interesting phenomenon is that cyclin E1 amplified
cancers are almost
always P16 high, so they express an endogenous
inhibitor of CDK4/6. So it appears that, and there's also
evidence for that, that there is a downside of having both hyperactive CDK2
and active CDK4/6 on top of it. So it's either/or in most
cases. There was, I think in this panel, two exceptions, which
had low P16, and this explains that
then CDK4/6 is active at the same time as CDK2 and
pure cyclin E1 degradation doesn't work.
This is a very rare occurrence based on TCGA data in
amplified cancers, and one was an RV loss of function.
Again, very rare, but that was a natural knockout, if you will,
or mutation.
Yeah. In that case, in the clinical trials, in the future, will you,
besides CCNE1 amplification, will add other
biomarkers to select patient?
Yeah. So we are not ready to disclose the clinical development strategy yet,
but we are definitely aware of that and thinking of that angle, yes.
Okay, thank you.
That will be taken into account.
One more question in the room.
Hi. Very nice presentation. I had a question related to the
durability of your PD response in vivo. I noticed BID dosing.
So for how long do you see your PD inhibition?
Yeah. We have tested various regimens, and if we give
high enough dose, we don't need BID,
even in mice. And in humans, this might be different.
We haven't done any long-term washout experiments to see how
long the degradation lasts.
But in general, we see very durable degradation of our targets
across programs.
Yeah. One more question here.
So-
We don't have any more. Sorry. We going to have some time at the end of this
session. If you don't mind, we
can have more question there.
It's a yes or no question, very quick.
So does the compound degrade cyclin E2?
No.
Thank you, Ralf. Our next speaker is Dr.
Zhang Yang from Degron Therapeutics.
He will present the data on the molecular glue degrader of the RNA binding
protein HuR.
Okay. Good afternoon, everyone. It's my great honor
to stand here on behalf of Degron
Therapeutics to present our
recent research and development progress on HuR
degraders.
First, I would like to start with a brief introduction of HuR.
Human antigen R,
often
encoded by the ELAVL1 gene,
is a RNA-binding protein that plays
critical roles in driving cancer, inflammation, and
metabolic disorders. HuR is
frequently overexpressed or cytoplasmic-enriched in
many cancer
types,
particularly in response to certain stresses, including
oncogenic mutations and chemo-targeted therapies.
Although HuR has long been considered as a
promising cancer target, it has remained undruggable
using conventional approaches. Multiple modalities
have been investigated recently.
However, none has advanced beyond the preclinical stage
due to the substantial technical challenges.
As Jessica mentioned, molecular glue degraders
has emerged as a strategy to target
traditionally undruggable proteins.
Molecular glue degraders can
generate a neomorphic surface, crBN,
after binding, which enabled the
recruitment and degradation of neo-substrates.
We, Degron Therapeutics, focuses on developing novel
MGDs,
and has established a proprietary compound
library based on molecular glue degraders,
which comprise
rapidly expanding and structural diverse
compound library with more than 10,000 compounds.
And to be mentioned, our compound library
has
more than 150 novel diverse cores,
which is different from the
widely used selenamide cores.
And most of these compounds proven cell
binding.
And the candidates in our compound library are
further evaluated using advanced screening and
validation systems, including induced
proximity TurboID mass spec and protein abundance
mass spec.This strategy has enabled the
systematic identification of novel
MGDs
for multiple targets,
including HUR.
The discovery of HUR is a
classic example of the proteomic screening strategy.
CRBN wild type and knockout cells were treated with
randomly pooled compounds from the library and subjected
to global quantitative
proteomics. As we can see in the figures,
after the treatment with the molecular compound pool, the protein
level of HUR was significantly reduced, and this
reduction was not observed in CRBN knockout cells,
suggesting the presence of a HUR molecular glue within the pool.
Encouraged by the screening results, we next
evaluated the HUR degradation in response to
individual compounds and identified the HUR degrader one.
Further library screening and MedChem
optimization yielded HUR degrader two,
which exhibited a stronger CRBN binding affinity and
HUR degradation potency, whose DC50
was improved to 3.8 nanomolar from 40 nanomolar,
and the maximum of degradation at 10 micromolar was
improved to 96% from 88%.
Next, multiple experiments were conducted to verify
the CRBN and the proteasome dependency of the HUR degradation.
Treatment of a proteasome inhibitor, MG132,
prevented the decrease of HUR induced by our
HUR degrader.
In CHX chase assay,
a significantly shortened
protein half-life could be observed
after the degrader treatment in
CRBN wild type cells, but not in CRBN knockout cells.
These results suggested that
the HUR molecular glue relies on CRBN and the proteasome system to
accelerate the degradation of the targeted proteins.
Moreover, in in vitro polyubiquitination
assay, we also observed the
polyubiquitination of HUR,
confirming its mechanism of action as a molecular glue.
To elucidate the ternary complex formation, we determined
the
cryo-EM structure of DDB1CRBN,
MGD and HUR at a 3.3 angstrom resolution.
Our
structure revealed that HUR binds to
CRBN using its G58 loop, which
is a
type of beta hairpin loop.
The degrader makes multiple contacts within the complex.
For example, its glutamyl ring fits into
CRBN's triple tryptophan pocket,
but also forms a hydrogen bond with the side chain of
H378.
Its benzofuran core stacks against this tryptophan,
proline, and the histidine, while its pyrazole moiety sits close
to HUR's G58 loop.
The phenyl tail points toward the F150
of CRBN, likely stabilizing a closed
conformation
of CRBN. We also noticed that
direct interaction between HUR and the CRBN,
here, a hydrogen bond forms between HUR's arginine and the
CRBN's glutamate,
while no direct binding was detected without
the HUR degrader.
With a
potent HUR degrader in hand, we turned to evaluate
the HUR-dependent cellular
vulnerability to find the proper indication.
Analysis of that data showed a strong and
positive correlation between HUR
dependency and BRAF.
Since BRAF
mutations are prevalent in skin and colorectal
cancers, we suppose that a BRAF mutant colorectal
cancer might be particularly sensitive to
HUR degradation. A proof of concept
study across the 13 CRC cell lines confirmed the
hypothesis. Here, HUR degrader
selectively reduced the cell
viability in all the six BRAF mutant cell
lines, while the BRAF wild-type cell
lines remained resistant despite efficient HUR
degradation. Thus, BRAF
mutant CRC was chosen as the
indication for further evaluation.
To develop a new therapy for BRAF mutant CRC,
we would like to find the differentiation or
advantages over the current BRAF inhibitors.
BRAF dabrafenib-resistant MDSDN cells
were generated through long-time exposure.
As expected, these resistant cells showed a clear loss of
sensitivity to dabrafenib compared with this parental
compound.
In contrast, when treated with our HUR
degraderBoth parental compound and
dabrafenib-resistant cells
displayed strong and comparable
reductions in cell viabilities.
And
MAPK signaling evaluation also confirmed
the pathway inhibition. Together,
these
results suggest that our QRI degrader could provide
a new therapeutic strategy to overcome
or bypass the resistance to BRAF inhibitor in BRAF
mutant CRC.
Next, we turned to evaluate the
in vivo efficacy of QRI degrader.
Oral administration of our QRI degrader for 14
days
exhibited a dose-dependent
tumor growth
inhibition. And the strongest
suppression could be found at the three mg per kg
dose and the dose levels above. Moreover,
in a BRAF mutant
CRC PDX model, our QRI degrader also
demonstrated a strong
tumor growth control
across multiple dose levels.
Notably, a single agent anti-EGFR, BRAF inhibitor
or
MEK inhibitor did not cause the regression of this
PDX model, while the treatment of our QRI
degrader on large tumors could lead to a
significant tumor regression.
Given the promising
results of the QRI degrader treating BRAF mutant CRC,
lead optimization
afforded DG6498,
which exhibited favorable
ADME and PK properties.
PD wise, DG6498 demonstrated a
robust and a sustained targeted degradation at low
dose levels. It's consistent with the catalytic
mechanism of molecular glue degraders.
And the DG6498's safe and
efficacious clinical dose levels were predicted through modeling,
integrating mouse tumor models, and monkey PK/PD
data. And the prediction also supports once
daily dosing for this compound.
Based on this promising profile, DG6498
is currently in clinical development in patients for
BRAF mutant CRC and other solid tumors.
A
first-in-human study in participants with solid tumors
is currently enrolling.
Okay. That's all for my presentation, and
thanks to all the team
members of the Degron Therapeutics. Thank you.
Thank you. We have time for one or two questions.
Maybe I can get started with the questions.
In your
resistant model, BRAF
inhibitor model, your phospho-ERK is gone
in 24 hours with your degraders, and in the parental line,
it was later. Can you comment on that?
The slide 10.
Do you mean this?
Oh.
Sorry. Because I'm a chemist, so I'm not very
familiar with this
biology data.
All right.
Yeah.
If there's no other questions, we can move on to the next one.
Please join me in thanking you again.
Thank you.
So our next speaker is Dr. James Theis from
BridgeBio Oncology Therapeutics.
He will present data on the RAS PI3K alpha
breaker.
Good afternoon, everyone. I'd like to thank the organizers for the
opportunity to present our work today on BBO10203,
a RAS PI3 breaker, and how it inhibits phospho-AKT signaling in
HER2-amplified models through inhibition of non-canonical RAS signaling.
Here are my disclosures.
In the normal setting,
receptor tyrosine kinases are activated by growth factors, which then go on to
activate the PI3K alpha complex, which is comprised of a
p85 and p110 subunit, leading to activation of
phospho-AKT and downstream effectors, which in normal cells results in cell
growth and glucose metabolism. However, in the malignant context,
as we're all familiar with, RAS becomes hyperactivated in a
large number of settings, and in addition to driving increased MAP kinase
signaling here, as shown on the right, interacts with PI3K alpha,
leading to increased activation of AKT in those same set of effectors.
But in this setting, leads to increased proliferation and survival, which
results in tumorigenesis.
Initially, the importance of this interaction was established by
genetic methods in which they introduced point mutations in
the RAS binding domain of p110. And by introducing those mutations,
they were shown to not only block the interaction of PI3K with
RASBut block downstream signaling, and most importantly here, as
shown on the graph on the far right, block tumor formation in a KRAS
G12D-driven lung tumor model. Now, it's important
to note that this blockade of tumor formation in this model
was not observed with any of the metabolic toxicities that are typically observed
with PI3K inhibitors in the clinic, such as hyperglycemia.
So for this reason, we developed BB010203, a
RAS PI3K small covalent breaker of the RAS PI3K
interaction. As shown here, BB010203
binds within the RBD of P110 alpha and does not inhibit its
kinase activity.
Instead, its activity is agnostic to the
mutational status of either RAS partner or PI3K partner.
It's active at extremely potent in vitro and in vivo
concentrations, as shown here in the table on the bottom right.
And importantly, in preclinical models, it leads to tumor regressions
with no observed signs of hyperglycemia, even when given at higher exposures than
the regressions that are observed.
So the first question we had with 10203 was, in which
context is the biology of RAS PI3K important
for growth and AKT activation? So to do this, we
did a large number of cell line screens, and here I'm just showing a
snippet in which we identified that HER2-amplified lines were particularly
sensitive to the disruption of RAS with PI3K.
So here we can see with treatment with 10203, we can show potent
single-digit nanomolar complete suppression of phospho-AKT, followed
by moderate suppression on KRAS and PIK3CA mutants, and no
activity in PTEN null lines.
Importantly, that in vitro
potent activity translated in vivo, where we could show strong monotherapy effects
of 10203 with dose-dependent reductions in tumor volumes
and regressions at 30 mgs per kg in the HER2-amplified
KYSC
esophageal CDX model.
We next wanted to validate these mechanisms genetically using those same set of
mutations in which we introduced earlier.
And so we CRISPRed in the RBD mutations within P110 in a
number of cell lines and asked the question, at what frequency were those
alleles lost over time?
And that would be an indication of the sensitivity of those lines to the
disruption of RAS with PI3K.
And what we observed is that the most sensitive lines were, again, those lines that
had HER2 amplification, such as BT474 and KYSC,
followed by lines that had mutations in KRAS or PIK3CA, and then
lines that had mutations
resulting in PTEN loss of function showed minimal loss of those alleles.
And this data highly recapitulated the data that we saw on the previous slide with
10203.
It's also important to note that when we introduced those same RBD mutations in
P110 in HER2-amplified lines, we saw a marked reduction in
phospho-AKT, as shown in the boxes here in the red.
This data shows by genetic mechanisms that
the PIK3CA RAS interaction is essential for
phospho-AKT activation and survival.
So to understand what RAS isoforms were driving this dependency, the first thing we
did is we screened our panel of our two amplified lines against
with 10203 compared to the pan-RAS inhibitor
6236. And what we observed is that with
10203, as expected, we saw complete phospho-AKT
suppression. But with the pan-RAS inhibitor RMC-6236,
we saw moderate suppression of phospho-AKT, despite seeing
complete phospho-ERK suppression.
This was seen across a larger panel of lines, here shown on the right.
So this data to us indicated that
the phospho-AKT activity in these lines was not likely driven from canonical
RAS proteins, which were inhibited by the RMC-6236, but likely coming from
non-canonical proteins, which were not hit by 6236.
So to validate that,
we then went in, in our HER2-amplified line and asked the question, which RAS
isoform was driving the majority of that activation by doing SIs against
individual RAS isoforms known to interact with P110.
And so this plot here is just showing that of all the
SIs knocking down the individual RAS isoforms, the non-canonical RAS
isoform RS2 showed the most pronounced effect on phospho-AKT
reduction of the RAS isoforms tested.
But you can also appreciate that it's not to the same extent noticed by
10203.
And we think that was potentially due to the redundancy and the compensation of
additional RAS isoforms acting to increase the level of
phospho-AKT when you knocked one down.
So to address this, we then went in and then did a combination
of multiple siRNAs against RS as well as RS2, which
are both again in the non-canonical family member.
And we can see with that combined approach, we could see a marked reduction of
phospho-AKT.
And then when we went in and did combined addition of the
pan-RAS inhibitor 6236, that was further able to bring the level down to
that seen with 10203 comparably.
We also validated these results in additional lines, such as
BT474, shown here, and others. And this data
supports that non-canonical RAS proteins play a large and important
role in driving the majority of the phospho-AKT signaling, but canonical signaling
is still important to inhibit, and that 10203
inhibits both arms of this pathway.
Now to get a better understanding of what role non-canonical RAS proteins
were playing in HER2 activation, we next turned to a series of
co-IPs in which we pulled down the non-canonical
RAS protein RS2 and asked what is it associating with.
And we found, as we kind of expected, that RS2 interacted with
p85 and P110.But it also activated
with active HER2 and HER3, and that was both in KYC and
BT474. And this is still something that's ongoing, and we
continue to test the effects of different breaker and glue molecules in this
setting to understand how that interferes with this complex formation.
But however, it leads us to a model in which we believe, and this is again
ongoing, but we believe that RS2 orchestrates the active
assembly of
a HER2 complex leading to
phospho-AKT activation. And again, the exact mechanism for how the breaker
interferes with this complex formation is an active area of investigation within
our lab.
Now, switching gears just a little bit, but
from what I just showed you, given the orthogonal method of inhibition of the
breaker and comparing that to the conventional mechanisms of
HER2-targeted therapies that will either target the
extracellular domain or the kinase domain, we believe there could be strong
combination potential with the breaker and clinically approved
HER2-targeted agents. So to test that in BT474
cell lines, which is a HER2-amplified model,
we gave the combined
approach of 10203 in combination with tucatinib here on the left
or trastuzumab here on the right. And what you can see in blue is strong
monotherapy effects with 10203. But when you combine that with the other
agent, it led to strong regressions.
In addition, in the HER2-amplified N87CDX model,
we compared the efficacy of
BBO10203 to the HER2 small molecule inhibitor
tucatinib. And what we observed is that 10203, again in
blue, outperformed tucatinib as a single agent.
And when given in combination with the HER2 targeting antibody
trastuzumab, led to strong regressions, and again, outperformed the
combination of tucatinib plus trastuzumab.
So hopefully these last two slides prove the point
that the 10203 has strong combination potential when given with
clinically approved HER2 targeting agents and potentially can overcome some of
their shortcomings.
I'm going fast here, but
in summary,
I hope to have proved to you that HER2-amplified cells are particularly
sensitive to the disruption of RAS with PI3K, and
that can be shown through either small molecule treatment with
10203 or by genetic methods by introducing
RAS binding domains within p110 to show that those lines are
sensitive on phospho-AKT and survival.
I hope to have shown to you that the phospho-AKT that's driven in those
cells is majorly driven by non-canonical RAS signaling, but that
canonical signaling also plays a role, and you need to inhibit both, and
10203 has the properties to do that.
And that in preclinical models, that 10203 shows strong
combination potential in HER2-amplified models with either tucatinib
or trastuzumab.
And we hope that
that data reads out well
with 10203 as it's currently enrolling in the Phase
1 Breaker-101 clinical trial.
Now, I'd like to thank and acknowledge the team at BBOT,
as well as our collaborators at the RAS Initiative at Frederick National Labs and
Lawrence Livermore National Labs.
I'd also like to thank you all for your attention, and I'm happy to take any
questions.
We have time for a few questions.
Maybe I, again, will start with the first question or
a simple question. As a chemist, I was wondering, you used
one of the negative control there.
I assume this is another enantiomer of your molecule, or it's a different
atropisomer?
In this slide deck?
Yeah, slide number seven.
So this is all genetic.
With apelesib, that's our positive control here, and then-
Negative control, it's another small molecule?
Negative control, sorry, would be our DMSO non-treated.
Okay.
Sorry about that.
Thank you.
Quick question.
So it's interesting that you see deeper responses in the
combination with the HER2, but it's also a
very proximal downstream combination to basically deepen.
But I'm curious if you're working towards more
orthogonal pathway combinations as we're seeing in the RAS world happen
now.
With HER2-targeted agents or just broadly?
Any other non-HER2, a little bit less
proximal to where your compound is actually
targeting.
Yeah. With the breaker, I think outside of
HER2 monotherapy, a lot of the effects there are driven
by combination agents, especially with MAP kinase inhibition.
So we're doing a lot of combinations where we're combining that with G12C
inhibitors, G12D inhibitors in lung and
pancreatic, and then combining that in different indications with
standard of cares with chemo and CRC, et cetera,
to go about some of those
vertical pathway inhibition as well as
combining with targets that should synergize.
Hopefully that answers your question.
All right.
Julian.
You see the
complex of RS2 with
p110 alpha
in your co-IP's. Do you see that go away with
BBO10203 treatment?
That's something that we're working on right now.
We're
just testing that at
its current state, so it's a little too early to report whether or not it breaks
that interaction at the cellular level.
Sorry.
Okay. Thank you, James.
Thank you.
Our next speaker is Dr. Christine Jensen-Paggacas
from Pfizer. Dr. Jensen-Paggacas will present data on a
catalytic inhibitor of the KAT2A/B protein.
Good afternoon, everybody. I want to thank the organizers for the opportunity to
represent the KAT2 team at Pfizer and share some of our preclinical
data on our first-in-class KAT2A and B catalytic inhibitors in
multiple myeloma.
Here are my disclosures.
Right. Histone acetylation is a key epigenetic regulator of gene
expression, and cancer cells can exploit this to reprogram
transcription to support oncogenic activation, lineage
specificity, and define cell fate.
Now, KAT2A and B are the paralogs that provide the
catalytic acetyltransferase activity that are components of the SAGA
transcriptional coactivator complex shown here.
Now, transcription factors such as MYC and lineage-specific transcription factors
directly recruit SAGA to their target genes,
where KAT2A and B can then acetylate histones to drive
oncogenic output. Now, literature data supports a role
for KAT2 in driving MYC transcription, as well as cell cycle
regulation and hormone signaling.
Cancer cells also have selective dependencies on SAGA and KAT2A and
B. This has been shown in heme tumors such as multiple myeloma,
AML, as well as solid tumor indications.
Now, targeting acetylation is therapeutically actionable, and it's
clinically validated through the use of HDAC inhibitors, bromodomain
inhibitors, as well as more recently, KAT inhibitors.
But by targeting lysine acetyltransferases such as KAT2,
this offers a more selective epigenetic strategy than the more broad
HDAC or bromodomain inhibition.
So genetic data is what first led us to pursue multiple myeloma for our
KAT2 program. So what you're seeing here is this is a bit
of the DepMap data where we were asking in multiple myeloma cells
versus every other tumor type, what are the protein complexes that
myeloma cells are most dependent on?
And so we used the CRISPR dropout scores here.
We used a quorum protein complex analysis, and what you can see
here is that the SAGA complex and other
KAT2-containing complexes showed up as the top dependencies for
multiple myeloma, as are highlighted here in the red.
Now, if we look at this another way, and we just ask, based on a SAGA composite
score of all the SAGA members and their
average dropout scores in the DepMap, which tumor types
are the ones that are most sensitive to SAGA loss and KAT2 loss?
You see that the hematopoietic lineages are the top dropouts there
in the first row, with a lot of the most sensitive cell lines in this
panel being multiple myeloma, with also some AML as
well.
So because multiple myeloma was the most sensitive
indication to SAGA loss, and because KAT2A and
B are targetable, actionable
targets, we set out to find catalytic inhibitors
for a drug discovery program.
All right, so we identified our catalytic inhibitors to KAT2
through DNA encoded library screening.
We screened several billion compounds against KAT2A
protein, either in the presence or absence of the cofactor
acetyl-CoA.
When we got the hits, we confirmed them by several biophysical and
biochemical assays to confirm that they were not only binders and
inhibitors, but also that they are acetyl-CoA competitive
catalytic inhibitors of KAT2A and B.
So in the table here, you can see the original del screening hit,
the potency against KAT2A and KAT2B enzymes, as well
as the cellular biomarker H3K9 acetyl.
And you can see some of the progression that we did with our SAR for these
different compounds.
The compound B is the one that I will be sharing all the data on with
all of you today, so it will be referred to as KAT2I
in my subsequent data slides. And I just want to mention that
these compounds are over thousandfold selective over the other
lysine acetyltransferases.
All right, we first wanted to confirm the biomarker H3K9 acetyl,
so we did this through genetic studies where we knocked out either KAT2A
or KAT2B, or did a double knockout of both of them.
And what you can see here in this western blot is that to completely
remove the H3K9 acetylation, you need to do the double knockout of both
KAT2A and B, suggesting that they are paralogs that can compensate for one another.
We then performed a rescue experiment in the double knockout cells
where we re-express either KAT2A or KAT2B, and you can see that
the overexpression of either one of them is enough to rescue the
expression of the H3K9 acetylation.
We then took our compounds, and we looked at these by proteomics,
and this is the graph on the bottom, where we treated cells with
the inhibitor, and we did histone proteomics where there's a
panel of histone peptides with different post-translational modifications on them.
And we could see that the
largest decrease in the peptides were the ones that contained
H3K9 acetylation. So here we're able to show with our
catalytic inhibitor that we can phenocopy the loss of H3K9
acetylation that we see in our genetic models.
So we then wanted to understand what the tumor intrinsic response to our compound
would be. So we used a panel of multiple myeloma cell lines to
test sensitivity. And you can see here by the responders, which are
in green, that we have broad activity across the multiple
myeloma cell line panel seen here.
So we wanted to understand what that mechanism of cell death
was.All right. So we started out
by looking at RNA-Seq to understand what the transcriptional
signatures were that were affected by treatment with our drug.
So we tested both sensitive cell lines and insensitive cell lines to understand
that. So from the ones that are boxed there with the purple, these
are our sensitive cell lines, and what you can notice are that some of the most
strongly downregulated pathways shown in the heat map in blue are
MYC target genes as well as E2F target genes.
We also see an increase in some of the inflammatory signatures as well,
which is shown in the red, and I will cover that a little bit later in
the talk.
But starting with the tumor intrinsic mechanisms and the fact that we
knew that SAGA has been a reported MYC
transcriptional co-activator, we started in on
with the MYC mechanism.
So we utilized a MYC reporter system here where we have
the MYC's E-box elements
fused to luciferase and tested this reporter construct.
And you can see here by the graph, we can show that we have a dose-dependent
decrease in this MYC-activated reporter when treated with our
KAT2 inhibitors. So we think that the downregulation
of these MYC target genes is one of the mechanisms by which we are having a tumor
intrinsic response in multiple myeloma cells.
All right. We then wanted to make sure that our compounds would be orally available
to do in vivo studies with. So this is the plasma exposure
in mice at three different doses of our compound here.
What you can see is that we can cover, for the most part, the
IC50 of H3K9 acetyl biomarker. This is the
cellular amount at all of these doses for the
twenty-four-hour dosing period.
We then took these into tumor-bearing mice to look at the
biomarker modulation of H3K9 acetylation.
What you can see here at these two different doses is that we have
sustained target coverage over twenty-four hours of at least seventy-five
percent inhibition of the H3K9 biomarker.
All right. We then wanted to understand whether our drugs could
combine with standard of care agents.
So the first ones we tested were IMiDs, since these are standard of care
agents in multiple myeloma. So we combined our KAT2 inhibitor with
either lenalidomide or pomalidomide in a combination matrix experiment
for proliferation in vitro. We used Gene Data Screener
to analyze the synergy data. So when you
get this output data, if you get a value between zero to one, this is
considered additive, and you can see this by the column on the right
where we have the self-cross of our compound with itself and those values
range there. If you have a value that's greater than one, this suggests you can
have synergy between the two compounds, and you can see for both our
KAT2 inhibitor combination with lenalidomide and pomalidomide, most of
the cell lines we observe synergistic scores.
So we wanted to take that in vivo. So I circled here the OPM2.
This is the tumor model that we ran here. Whoops, sorry.
Went backwards.
This is the tumor model that we used to test this combination.
So what you can see is that our monotherapy in the light blue of our KAT2
inhibitor has nice tumor growth inhibition on its own,
which beats the standard of care pomalidomide and dexamethasone, which is shown
in green. But that the triple combination of the KAT2 inhibitor plus
pomalidomide and dexamethasone does show that combination
benefit that was predicted by our in vitro studies.
So we were pretty excited about this.
All right. Then I've just shown you some of the tumor intrinsic data that we've
seen
with our inhibitors, but we did observe in our RNA-Seq signature
some upregulation of interferon signatures as well as
interferon-stimulated genes, and we wanted to understand what the
possible mechanism of our drug on innate immune
signaling would be.
So what you're looking at here in the western blot is we treated several
multiple myeloma cell lines with our compound, and you can see that we
do see increases in both IRF7 and IRF9
proteins, and this corresponds to the loss of H3K9
acetylation. So we wanted to follow up with some of the
signaling. So we also used a reporter line here with this
ISRE reporter, and you can see we observed dose-dependent
increases in the reporter function with KAT2 inhibitor
treatment.
So this increase in interferon signaling
then leads to increased secretion of chemokines and
cytokines. In this model, we can see an increase in
CCL5 and CXCL10, which of course, are important
chemoattractants for T cells in the tumor microenvironment.
So we then utilized a mouse syngeneic model of multiple
myeloma to test tumor growth inhibition in
combination with BCMA CD3 bispecific
antibody.
So the shaded area in this tumor growth study is the time by which we were
dosing. So we dosed two doses of the antibody at
day one and day eight. We did twenty-one days of daily dosing with our
KAT2 inhibitor, and then we removed drug and did a tumor growth delay
experiment to see how that recovered.
So what you can notice is that for the bispecific
antibody in green, it has very good tumor growth
inhibition on its own, but we can still appreciate combination benefit when we
add the KAT2 inhibitor in purple. But
additionally, what you can see also is that we do extend the tumor
growth delay in a dose-dependent manner when we add our KAT2
inhibitor with the bispecific antibody.
And this is reflected in the survival curve shown on the
right.
So we're very excited about the idea that this could potentially open up
opportunities to combine our KAT2 inhibitor with IO therapies to
deepen responses in multiple
myeloma.All
right. So in summary, what I've shown you today is that
inhibition of CAT2 can reduce oncogenic pathway
activation, for example, with MYC signaling.
CAT2 inhibition may sensitize tumors to immune cell killing through an
upregulation of interferon responses.
And I showed you that our catalytic inhibitors are able to demonstrate robust tumor
growth inhibition, either as a monotherapy or in combination with standard of care
agents such as IMIDs and T-cell engagers.
And we're very excited about this dual mechanism of tumor intrinsic and
tumor immune modulation and how this might play out in the
clinic. So I
want to thank the team. I know there's a lot of people here, but we couldn't get
them all in a picture. So these first-in-class drugs,
they take a lot of time and a lot of years to develop.
And so all of these folks contributed to this project team.
But I do want to call out people on the left, Sean O'Connell and Sasa Ninkovic, who
were the biology and chemistry leads of this pre-clinical program,
fantastic scientists, and all the folks on the left-hand side who
contributed to the data that's in this presentation today.
So thank you for your attention, and I'll answer any questions you might have.
Thank you. Now some questions.
Hi, Mike.
Hi. Really, really impressive. Really nice talk. Two quick questions for you.
Mm-hmm.
Very cool to see that you got a start off of a DEL library.
You noted billions and billions of compounds, and was wondering if the plus and
minus acetyl-CoA was kind of the
magic sauce for you in order to be able to do that.
And if so, can you just keep going back now and kind of just
hit many, many family members that you have that you're interested in?
And then the second question is,
with respect to the functional readout that you were seeing from RNA-Seq
and hitting MYC and E2F,
is this helping us understand context-specific
roles of lysine acetyltransferases with some of these gene
regulatory mechanisms, or do you have an opportunity
beyond multiple myeloma in a solid tumor setting where you have MYC
E2F-driven tumors?
Sure. Okay, so for the first question, the way that we do the DEL screens, because
we were specifically looking for a catalytic inhibitor that was
acetyl-CoA competitive. So we put those features into our
screen on purpose so that we can look for inhibitors, not just binders,
because we weren't looking for bromodomain binders to CAT2, which it does have a
bromodomain. So it was just the screen was designed that way, and
certainly that strategy can be used for other lysine acetyltransferases
as well.
For the second question is, for the MYC,
certainly, that's relevant in multiple myeloma and other solid tumors.
But with the context specificity, I think it's also with the
lineage-specific transcription factors, like SAGA has been shown to be
sensitive in AR-driven prostate cancer and other solid tumors
such as lung cancer. And certainly, these compounds could be applied to
other tumor types in addition to myeloma, for sure.
Great talk. I just want to ask a quick question about
CAT2A and CAT2B, because your title mentioned that
this is a dual degrader compound B.
But in the later studies, most of the assays
target CAT2A.
So could you talk about it? Are the team pursuing CAT2B, CAT2A,
dual degrader, or you
can just target CAT2A?
Right. So these are not degraders. These are catalytic inhibitors.
So we use the CAT2A protein. CAT2A is the
predominant paralog between the two, but that is what we used to do for our
screening. But through our SAR, we do screen against both
CAT2A and CAT2B. So we found dual inhibitors.
Yeah.
Thank you, Christine.
Thank you.
Our last speaker of the day is Dr. Jacqueline Smith, Chief Scientific
Officer at Revolution Medicines, and she will present
the discovery of a new class of mutant-targeted catalytic RAS
oncogene inhibitor.
Okay.
The privilege of being last. I just wanted to, on behalf of RevMed and my
co-authors, thank the organizers for giving us the opportunity here to share with
you the data on a new class of mutant-targeted catalytic RAS oncogene
inhibitors.
These are my disclosures.
RAS is a small GTPase that toggles between a GDP-bound
off state and a GTP-bound on state.
In normal cells, this is tightly regulated to control cell growth.
Mutations in RAS, particularly at G12, G13, and Q61,
lead to accumulation of RAS in the on state, and this drives excessive
signaling and uncontrolled growth.
And this is the main driver of RAS-addicted cancers, which are some of the
most devastating of human cancers.
Under normal conditions, RAS is activated in response to growth factors, which
promote the GEF-mediated exchange of GDP for GTP.
This leads to a conformational change in RAS that allows it to now interact with
downstream effectors and drive signaling and then growth and
proliferation. RAS is inactivated by hydrolysis of the bound
GTP back to GDP, and this is stimulated by
endogenous GTPase activating proteins or GAPs.
Oops, sorry, wrong way.
Oncogenic mutations in RAS disrupt this regulation and, in a majority of
cases, disable this GAP-mediated hydrolysis.
This leads to accumulation in the on state, and hence uncontrolled cell growth and
proliferation, which is underlying the cancer.
Oops, I'm going the wrong way. Sorry.
Thus far, there's really been two major classes of RAS inhibitor.
The first class is the RAS off inhibitors.
These are switch two pocket binders that bind preferentially to the off state, and
the pioneers of this class being sotrastaurin and adagrasib, and they lead to
accumulation of RAS in this or they trap RAS in this inactive
state that is incompetent for signaling.The other class of inhibitors is
the molecular glues or tricomplex inhibitors.
These bind exclusively to the on state of RAS.
They do so by engaging with an endogenous chaperone protein called cyclophilin
that then forms a neomorphic protein interface that binds to GTP-bound
RAS. The formation of this tricomplex sterically occludes RAS
interaction with downstream effectors, as exemplified here with an
overlay with CRAF.
Today, I would like to introduce a third class of inhibitors. Oh, my goodness.
That basically catalytically inactivate RAS and then
essentially stimulate the hydrolysis of RAS GTP to RAS GDP
and mutant RAS, and in so doing, mimic the activity of
natural gaps at wild-type RAS.
So one might ask, why do we need yet another class of RAS inhibitor given that we
already have off and the on inhibitors?
And I think that while there are a varied number of different types of
molecule there with different mutant selectivities and different features, and
several of those are already providing nice clinical benefit to patients, perhaps
most recently exemplified by the data we released last week with
deraxone rasip in our RASloot 302 study in pancreatic cancer.
But RAS is a challenging target, I think, as many of you know, and
we need to come forward with multiple therapeutic options to offer long-term
benefit to patients. In particular, it's now emerging under
therapeutic pressure from both RAS on and RAS off inhibitors that these
tumors escape by reactivating oncogenic RAS signaling.
This is exemplified here by some data from our own phase one two study with
deraxone rasip where we looked at ctDNA in patients who had
progressed on deraxone. What we saw was that those where we could detect
genomic alterations, those converged on the RAS pathway.
So this on-treatment resistance is clearly an emerging medical need, and
strategies to overcome this are required.
So one of the strategies that we have taken at RevMed is to come forward
with novel inhibitors that we believe will work in this setting of increased
oncogenic flux. To do so, we've built on the
hydrolysis-stimulating properties of deraxone rasip and
leveraging our sort of deep and really sophisticated understanding of the
tricomplex SAR, been able to engineer RAS on inhibitors
specifically designed to accelerate GTP hydrolysis of
G12 mutants and essentially restore them back to the GDP
state.
So here is RAS on. RAS on. Here is RMO-55, a
catalytic RAS on inhibitor of G12 mutant RAS.
It mimics the activity of natural gaps and stimulates the hydrolysis of GTP to
GDP, and it is shown by the biochemical data on this slide.
So on the left-hand side, what we have done is we have incubated G12V GTP in
the presence of SipA bound to the tricomplex inhibitor,
excess levels of the binary complex, and monitored the
stimulation of that GTP to GDP hydrolysis by monitoring
GTP levels. In the control, you can see there is minimal hydrolysis
consistent with the low intrinsic hydrolysis of the G12 mutant.
Deraxone rasip produces a modest stimulation of that hydrolysis.
But in contrast, RMO-55 produces a rapid and almost
complete reduction in G12V GTP levels.
On the right-hand side, we have looked at the ability of these
SipA TCI binary complexes to disrupt RAS RAF
complexes. Importantly, in this experiment, we used the RAS RAF
complex in excess of the binary complex, with
a tenfold excess here. So under these conditions, a stoichiometric
inhibitor would not be able to effectively disrupt this complex.
And as you can see in the bar graph below, deraxone rasip barely
produces the disruption of this complex.
But in contrast, RMO-55 produces a rapid and near
complete disruption of this complex consistent with a catalytic mechanism of
action.
We then moved into cells, and first we looked at the ability of the
RMO-55 to reduce cellular RAS GTP levels using a panel
of RASless MEFs engineered to express G12 mutants.
In the upper panel, you can see the data for deraxone rasip, which is primarily
a steric inhibitor. This compound does produce some reduction in cellular RAS
GTP levels, but this is incomplete.
However, the compound is obviously able to inhibit phospho-ERK in these cells, and
this is a function of the steric occlusion mechanism.
In contrast, RMO-55 produces a potent and near
complete reduction in cellular RAS GTP levels,
and this in turn is associated with a potent reduction in
phospho-ERK levels.
We profiled the activity of RMO-55 across a panel of over 800
cell lines in collaboration with the Broad Prism Lab.
And shown here are the data for the RAS G12 lines as well as
the RAS wild-type lines.
You can see that both deraxone rasip on the left and
RMO-55 on the right produced a robust inhibition of
G12 cell proliferation as reflected by a reduction in the AUC.
However, that effect was more robust for RMO-55 than for
deraxone rasip.
Deraxone rasip also has an effect on wild-type cell lines, as shown here.
However, we saw a much-reduced effect of RMO-55 on the
wild-type cell lines.
We first profiled the in vivo activity of RMO-55 following oral
administration by looking at the PK/PD relationship for inhibition of the
RAS pathway in both tumor and normal tissue as represented by
mouse ear skin, and this is in a G12D mutant model.
You can see on the left-hand side that deraxone rasip produces a potent inhibition
of tumor RAS pathway activation as measured by DUSP6
levels, and similarly has activity in normal tissue with some modest
selectivity over inhibition in normal tissue.
RMO-55 produces a very potent inhibition of RAS pathway signaling in the
tumor with significant selectivity over that in the normal ear
skin. The inhibition in the ear skin is a function of wild type
inhibition due to steric occlusion that is apparent at these higher
exposures.We profiled the activity of
RMO-55 across a panel of CDX, PDX, and syngeneic mouse
models,
and shown here are representative data for three models reflecting different
genotypes and different histotypes.
On the left-hand side is a G12D pancreatic model where we see very nice
dose-dependent inhibition of tumor growth with
RMO-55, and at the 10 MPK dose, we see deep and durable
tumor regressions. That dose also produced deep and durable
regressions in a G12C non-small cell lung cancer model,
as well as the G12V colorectal model.
And that RMO-55 was well-tolerated at all these doses.
So going back to the clinical resistance I started with, one of the major
mechanisms of clinical resistance, at least in terms of where we can detect a
mechanism of resistance from genomic alterations in ctDNA,
is KRAS amplification of the mutant associated with the
G12 mutant allele. So what we did here to model this was to
overexpress KRAS in a cell line and compare the activity of
the compounds in the parental cell line relative to the overexpression cell
line, and also looked at the activity in a normal skin cell,
keratinocyte cell line HaCaTs. So you can see that both compounds do show
a shift in sensitivity when you overexpress KRAS.
However, in the case of RMO-55, one is able to produce complete
inhibition of cell growth or proliferation at concentrations
associated with minimal effect on the normal keratinocyte cell line.
In contrast, deraxone rasib is also able to inhibit growth of the
KRAS overexpression cell lines, but this is only at concentrations that are also
associated with impact on the keratinocyte cell line.
Finally, we looked at the ability of RMO-55 in
settings where we have
got acquired resistance to RAS on multi-selective inhibition.
And so shown here on the left-hand side are two standard models
or parental models. In the upper panel, G12D PDAC, and in the
lower panel, G12C non-small cell lung cancer.
And here we're looking at the activity of 25 MPK deraxone
rasib. And you can see that it produces very nice
tumor regressions,
but eventually on treatment escape occurs.
We used these tumors that had escaped on treatment to establish
resistant models, which is shown in the middle panel here.
We confirmed that in these models, there was still evidence of RAS pathway
activation in the presence of deraxone rasib.
And of note in the G12C model, we were also able to detect increases
in G12C copy number as well as increases in KRAS expression.
As you'd expect, because these are resistant models, they had limited to no
sensitivity to deraxone rasib. However, RMO-55 at
10 MPK was able to produce deep and very durable regressions in
these resistant models.
In a related model, we looked at the ability of RMO-55
to restore tumor control in tumors that were already outgrowing
on deraxone rasib. And you can see here, these tumors initially showed
regression, but then started to grow out with continued deraxone rasib
treatment. However, in the group that we switched over to RMO-55,
we were able to restore tumor control and had durable regressions out to the end of
the study.
So in summary, we have discovered a new class of oral mutant-targeted catalytic RAS
inhibitor exemplified by RMO-55.
These mimic the activity of natural gaps stimulating the GTPase
activity of oncogenic RAS mutants.
We showed that RMO-55 reduces cellular RAS GTP levels and potently
inhibits cell proliferation in G12 mutant cell lines and is able to
drive deep and durable antitumor activity at well-tolerated doses.
We also showed that it's able to be active in the setting of acquired resistance,
particularly in mechanisms relevant to the clinical resistance mechanisms.
And collectively, these data support the clinical evaluation of this class of
compounds, and we look forward to advancing this compound into the
clinic towards the end of this year.
With that, I would like to thank all of the Revolution Medicines research and
development teams and the Broad Institute Prism Lab, and I'm happy to take
any questions.
We have time for questions. Uh,
go on.
Jen, that's beautiful work. I was wondering, have you
looked at the
impact of RMO-55 on the natural growth
factor-induced
GTP loading of wild-type RAS?
So we see activity even in the setting of growth factor
stimulation, if that's what you mean?
Yeah.
So, for example, in some of the models where we know we've got very strong growth
factor signaling, we'd still see activity because that would be a potential concern
is if you can overcome...
But I was thinking particularly in terms of just the normal
homeostatic signaling
from the growth factors to the wild-type RAS.
You're-
We see pretty significant cell activity, Julian.
Maybe I'm misunderstanding your question, over wild type
RAS expressing cell lines. And as you saw, those are the skin cells,
they're keratinocytes.
Mm-hmm. Great.
Thank you.
Hello. Very nice talk. So you see this generation of the
compound have a higher window between the wild type
and the cancer cells. So what it come from compared to the
first generation?
It's from the catalytic activity on the G12 mutants.
So we essentially have uncoupled
inhibition of the wild type and G12 through steric occlusion
by basically restoring the GTPase activity of the G12 mutants, and so you
basically extend that window.
So it's only restore the activity in G12 way, but-
G12.
Yeah, G12, but not in wild type.
No.
The wild type is already intact.
Okay.
Well, in a biochemical assay, you will stimulate activity, you will also stimulate
hydrolysis at wild type. But in a cellular context, you have endogenous
gapsWhich are already
converting GTP to GDP, not to mention that most of the wild type is already in the
GDP state.
Okay, understand. So in that way, have you seen actually a
larger therapeutic window in animal toxicity study
compared to the first generation?
I can't comment on that.
Okay. Thank you.
I think you show very nice data about GTR mutants,
but have you take a look at the G13D
as well as Q61H?
Sure. The G13 and some of the Q61, we have steric
occlusion activity analogous to the steric occlusion activity that I
described at wild type.
Mm-hmm. Okay. Thank you.
A very nice talk. So you show that the
RM-055 has stimulate the GTP
hydrolysis compared to daxonesib.
So compared to direct combo with the
RAS-off inhibitor, does this RM-055
provide the
advantage for the combo with the RAS-off inhibitor?
We are currently looking at a number of different combinations, and that is
obviously one we're interested in.
Okay, thanks.
Jan, over here.
Oh.
That was a lovely talk. So in principle, this drug is catalytic in its
mechanism of action, which is that one molecule of drug could, in principle,
stimulate the hydrolysis of 10 or 100.
Do you have any sense of what the stoichiometry then, of
how many molecules of drug do you need to get
complete hydrolysis, and what's the sort of catalytic efficacy of the
drug?
I don't have an answer to that question. You should ask Kyle.
But I do think, and you could probably notice this from the data, if you
overexpress KRAS, you still need to increase the levels of the
compounds. It's not like you can get away with infinitely small doses.
And I think, related to that, we know that every little bit of RAS signaling that
bleeds through is sufficient to potentially sustain growth.
So we still believe that you need relatively high concentrations.
So it's not down at sort of the completely substoichiometric.
However, the data that we show biochemically proves that it does have
substoichiometric activity.
Yeah.
But I don't know in terms of a cell context, Martin.
I don't know whether Kyle, you should find him afterwards.
He might have an opinion.
Okay, lovely. Thanks very much.
We have one more online question, and the question is: Do you expect
RM-055 to have
to be sensitive to resistance by lower at SIP A expression level
as seen in daxonesib?
We're currently exploring the resistance mechanisms, and certainly if you knock out
SIPA, this molecule will have no activity, like all of our tricomplex
inhibitors.
Thus far, we haven't seen that. We don't see that regularly even with
daxonesib. I'm not sure whether this will have a greater or lesser sensitivity, but
that's something we're obviously exploring.
Thank you.
Thank you. So at this point, we would like to open the floor to any question
to any of the speakers that we had today.
If anyone have a question, please line
up and ask those questions.
No?
Okay.
Yeah.
Oh, yeah. There is a question. Great.
I can start. I have one question to Olivia and also-
Okay.
... one to Christine.
All right. Olivia, can you come up, please?
Olivia.
James? Yeah. We have an online question for you.
Hi. You mentioned that
in SK-B-2 cells,
after your non-enzymatic HDAC inhibitor, you have
seen p53 activation.
Yes.
But do you know what is the mechanism?
Because SK-B-2 cells is a mutant p53.
And the transcription activation you have seen, so do you know the mechanism of
how p53 is activated?
You mean the SK-N-BE (2) C cells, so
that's like a neuroblastoma cell line?
Yes, exactly.
Yeah.
So they have in codon five, a mutation
which inhibit their DNA-binding activity.
Yes. So
it's basically,
the novel compound that
we identified, through gene set enrichment analysis, we
found that p53 goes up.
Okay.
And after p53 goes up, then the
cyclin-dependent kinase or p21 also goes up.
So it inhibits CDK2, and then your
RB retinoblastoma gets hypophosphorylated.
Yeah.
And it sequesters E2F.
Yeah, so I mean that you reactivate mutant p53 to
provide that.
Yes.
Okay.
Yeah.
We are yet to do actually experimental validations and
everything, so it's still pretty computational at this stage.
Okay.
And MYC is also getting strongly repressed and also glycolysis,
so maybe the other pathways also have some role.
Yeah.
And then I had another question to Christine.
Okay.
Go ahead.
Sure. Hi.
Yeah. Hi. I was wondering, do you know the mechanism of IRF
activation after CAT2A and CAT2B inhibition?
You're asking if it affects the IRF4 activation?
No.
Because in your reporter essay, luciferase,
in your model you had DNA, RNA, or TLR
activations, which leads to this activation
of interferons and-
Oh, right. Okay. You're asking about how we understand what the
induction of the immune response is?
Yes.
Yeah, that's a really good question.
We are trying to deconvolute that, so we sort of started at the end where we saw
that the gene signatures were there, and we're kind of backtracking.
There is some literature that has shown that it's potentially
through
a non-resolution of R-loops, and that could activate some of the RIG-I
pathways, but we haven't confirmed that yet.
So that's still under investigation.
Yeah, and second question was about the therapeutic window between
normal and cancer cells, because I think this SAGA complex is
also common in normal development process.
So what is your comment about the therapeutic window?
Well, what I can say about the compounds is that they have been well-tolerated in
our preclinical models. And certainly, SAGA does
have some dependencies in certain cancer cells.
And you're right, that the loss of CAT2A is embryonic
lethal. But in the adults, I think we have to investigate that and
see how it plays out. Yeah.
Thank you.
Yeah. Please. We have one last question online for
James.
And the question is: For the BB-BO10203
HER2 combination, is it mostly the HER2 amplify setting?
And what about HER2 mutant models?
It really depends on the HER2 mutant.
Mostly, it's in the HER2 amplified or overexpression setting.
And
typically, HER2 mutant lines that are resistant to traditional therapies do
not show as much of a combination benefit.
Thank you very much. All right. I think at this point we close the discussion.
Thank you all for speakers, and thank you for coming.